[Music]
in the 21st century we can't even
imagine what life would be like without
the internet Americans spend more than
10 hours a day in front of the screen
and the numbers just keep growing most
of us couldn't even spend a day without
our cell phone or our computer and this
is because the internet changed our
world forever make sure you watch this
video until the end to see how Google is
affecting our memory if this is your
first time watching our Channel
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up today
we're showing you 15 ways the Internet
has changed your life shopping a decade
ago if we wanted to go shopping we had
to ask our mom if we could go to the
mall and if we didn't live in a big city
the number of stores was really limited
in 2017 all we need is a credit card to
buy whatever we want from all over the
world we can even try to sell things
that we don't want anymore
that's why about 190 million US
consumers more than half of the
population is shopping online according
to Forrester Research and many of them
made 51 percent of their purchases
online according to comScore in 2016
some people might miss trying on clothes
but online sellers are making us with a
new experience we can get whatever you
want for a better price we can read many
reviews and we can even get our money
back if it doesn't work going to the
mall might have some advantages but will
often feel too lazy to leave our
computer and this is when online
shopping becomes very handy dating back
in the days if you wanted to date
someone you had to ask them face-to-face
or maybe you are a little too shy and
decided to send them a love letter or
ask your friend to talk to them but
nowadays online dating is much easier
and that's also it makes it more
complicated
according to eHarmony 40% of Americans
use online dating and 20 percent of
current committed relationships began
online however it comes with some
disadvantages as 53% of people lie on
their dating profile
22% ask a friend to create it and 48
percent of online relationships end
through email no matter what we think
that our favorite app is tinder it is
really easy to tell someone you like
them and to talk to them only if they
like you too but having so many choices
can also have some disadvantages when
you can easily go on a date with anyone
you can sometimes forget what makes it
so special we have to admit that we
sometimes miss the butterflies in our
tummy taking a photo 10 years ago we had
to bring a camera if we wanted to take
pictures with our friends taking photos
with our face
with something special and keeping them
in a photo album makes it feel more
precious but now that everyone has the
camera on their phone and that we can
easily share it with the world we're not
taking more pictures with our friends
we're taking more pictures of ourselves
there were almost 250 million selfies on
Instagram in 2016 and now sourcing and
frames directs estimated that the
average millennial spent about an hour a
week to take up to twenty five thousand
seven hundred selfies in their lifetimes
they also spend seven minutes on average
for each selfie and the most popular are
often just pictures of legs or someone's
pretty face taking a picture is not
about making memories anymore it's about
promoting ourselves
cheering pictures with our friends on
the Internet isn't a bad thing we just
wish that people could do it in a less
selfish way cooking when we left our
parents home to live on our own one of
the first things we asked our mom is how
to cook our favorite meal and those who
didn't have the chance to have a mother
who liked spending time in the kitchen
just had to turn to a cookbook but now
that everyone has access to thousands of
recipes online many of us think that we
have everything it takes to become chefs
that's why 35% of people looked at a
recipe online and 15%
Yuda cooking video that's what makes the
internet the most frequently used recipe
resource for home cooks we love our food
so much that 29% of people snapped a
photo of a dish they prepared however
just because you have the information
that you need doesn't mean that you have
the skills that's why many cooks feel
really confident until they realize that
they completely failed to their recipe
maybe we'll have to call mom to
understand how to make a souffle
exercising we know that with television
computers and smart phones came a more
sedentary lifestyle when we were young
we used to play outside and the only way
to see the world was to ride our bike
through the city but now that some
people are lazier than ever we also
found a way to exercise on the Internet
the best way to do it is by downloading
an app on our smartphone or watching a
video on the Internet
that's why 58 percent of mobile users
downloaded a health-related mobile app
according to Krebs and Duncan in 2015
and most of them use them at least daily
some apps help us keep track of how many
calories we are eating and spending well
others simply suggest many exercises we
can try at home this is how the internet
made us less active but this is also
what might give us the chance to become
healthier after all the internet simply
gave us more freedom and we can use it
to do whatever we want watching TV when
we
to watch television we need to make sure
that we were at the right time in the
right place to see our favorite show and
then we had to wait one more week to see
the following episode and we just ended
up watching boring things when there was
nothing on TV this is how streaming
services changed everything now we can
watch whatever we want whenever we want
and wherever we want in 2015
Netflix said that its members were
streaming 40 2.5 billion hours worth of
programming each individual subscribers
spent five hundred and sixty eight hours
a year watching Netflix on average which
is equivalent to around one hour 23
minutes per day we now have the freedom
to do what we want and the latest trend
is binge watching the first three
seasons of a show in two days and while
the internet gives everyone the chance
to be heard it is also part of the
reason why some people are making less
money no matter what the traditional
television will have to change if they
want to survive getting information our
parents used to read the newspaper every
morning to know what half of the day
before and now we just have to look on
social media to know what happened
seconds before and sometimes live on
Facebook we might think that we're
getting more information but what if we
were wrong the research carried out by
think-tank demos proof that Twitter
users are far more likely to interact
with people who think like them and see
publications that match their views it
means that if you like a politician you
will most likely see posts in favor of
this politician and you will miss the
information on why they might not be
that good this is what we call an echo
chamber but once again the Internet is
not only the problem but it can also be
the solution stop getting information on
social media and try to read many
different newspapers instead it is
important to read about different points
of view because you can't really know
what you're talking about without all
the information communicating
communication involved in many different
ways since the beginning of human
history only a few people knew how to
write and now most people in wealthy
countries have the chance to go to
school and we can talk to someone from
the other side of the world in less than
a second it became so easy to
communicate that it has become more
difficult we expect people to answer
quickly because they're always using
their phones and we are upset when they
don't communicating online also leads to
some problems like ghosting when someone
you're dating just stops answering your
messages according to plentyoffish
78% of single millennials have been
ghosted at least once while most people
think that this is really disrespectful
the ghosts just don't at the time to
face hard situations like a breakup
at anytime of the day no matter what we
think that communication is a great tool
and if we use it in the best way it will
also do great things reading if you're a
bookworm you probably love the smell of
a book going to the library was an
incredible adventure where you could be
transported to another universe simply
by turning a page but with the internet
we can now download whatever you want on
our smart phone or our tablet it has
become so easy that people even started
downloading them illegally to get a book
for free but what is worse is that most
people are not reading at all
the Pew Research Center reported in 2014
that nearly a quarter of American adults
have not read a single book in the past
year that number nearly tripled since
1978 but that doesn't mean that they're
not reading at all they're just reading
differently on the internet but we think
that book should get the attention that
they deserve so whether you're reading
them on paper or on a tablet it is time
to make them more popular again keeping
in touch back in the days if we wanted
to know what our friend is up to we had
to call them but since the invention of
social media all you have to do is log
in and see what they're doing online we
might think that it is now easier to
keep in touch with people but it
actually has a negative impact on our
well being that's because it feels like
social isolation even if we are
surrounded by people we think that it
will fulfill our needs by staying in
contact with others but it will actually
just make us feel more lonely moreover
knowing too much about what our friends
and partner are doing can make us feel
more jealous and we think that there is
a great way to solve this problem
instead of just looking at pictures of
your friends on vacation contacting old
friends and ask them if they want to
meet you at a restaurant to talk that's
the best way social media will really
help you keep in touch with people you
love playing two decades ago kids were
playing outside all the time and their
parents kept asking them to come back
home for dinner but nowadays our mom
just keeps begging us to play outside
for 30 minutes so we'll be a little more
active that's because it has become much
easier to live in the virtual world you
can do whatever you want with no
consequences and just try again if you
fail that's why people can even become
addicted according to psychologist
Douglas genteel roughly eight point five
percent of children who play video games
in the United States are addicted and
the numbers are similar across the world
the main problem is simply that they
have access to it because everyone has a
video game system or at least a computer
or a smartphone at home so after all
video games do have consequences in real
life maybe it would be time for them to
play outside instead you can fix a
broken bone
but getting rid of an addiction is more
difficult than what they might think
envying when we were young we used to
envy the kid who had a better looking
bike at school or who had the chance to
go on vacation with their parents every
year but now there are reasons to be
envious everywhere because people keep
showing us what they're doing online
that's why Instagram is not only one of
the most popular social media in the
world but also the worst social media
for mental health according to a recent
survey that's because it is associated
with high levels of depression anxiety
bullying and fear of missing out as
reported by time people see that their
friends are doing better things than
them which makes them feel worthless but
actually everyone posts what they want
to post on social media and that's why
we don't see that they are going through
hard things too but don't worry you can
still keep watching this video YouTube
received the highest marks for health
and well-being making it the only site
that received a positive score being
addicted most people used to think that
you could only be addicted to things
like cigarettes sugar or illegal
substances but you'll be surprised to
know that you're probably an addict too
that's because many people fear being
separated from their mobile phone which
is called nomophobia no mobile phone
phobia in the u.s. 65% of people sleep
with their smartphones as reported by
psychology today more than half never
switch off their phone and one in five
people would rather go without shoes for
a week than being separated from their
phones this is how in total 66 percent
of all adults suffer from nomophobia
that's crazy and there is one way to get
out of this situation you could try to
do it step by step by spending less and
less time with your cell phone if you
feel anxious you can also try to do
something healthier that will make you
feel better and if you really can't
stand being separated from your phone
the best thing to do would be to ask the
help of a professional
saving lives two decades ago when
someone needed help they had to make
sure that there was a phone nearby that
they could use and a century ago you
just had to hope that someone would be
nearby to give you a hand
no matter what we think about the
internet we have to admit that it is one
of the reasons why many people are still
alive today the internet is saving lives
one of the most important hunger relief
organizations the World Food Program
even makes the internet a top priority
when a disaster strikes that's because
they need to be able to communicate with
people in order to help them the United
Nations even declare that internet
access should be a human right even we
can use it in many situations being able
to call 9-1-1 on your smartphone or
simply ask for help online has already
saved many ly
and simply being able to get more
information about our health it's
sometimes what makes people change their
life to the better or ask for the help
of a professional so whether you like
the internet or not you will thank you
for being there when you're in trouble
researching when we had a question we
had to go to the library and open an
encyclopedia to try to find an answer
and we didn't always find it it was
mostly difficult we had to work on
homework at school but now everything is
easier because we just have to ask
Google we even turned it into a verb by
saying that we are googling something
that's how the internet became the
external hard drive for our memories
this is why people don't recall the
information itself when they're asking
themselves a question but recall instead
for where to access it according to
Sparrow and Wagner in 2011 so having
access to so much information is also
what makes us a little less smart did
the internet change your life in any
other way don't we try to tell us how in
the comments down below
we'd love to know what you think and
that's it for 15 ways the Internet has
changed your life for more stories like
this make sure you watch 10 products
you'll never buy again knowing how
they're made thanks for watching
[Music]